I want to repeat that everyone everyone
must follow the advice to protect
themselves and their families but also
more importantly to protect the wider
public
so stay at home for seven days if you
think you have the symptoms remember the
two key symptoms a high temperature a
continuous new cough whole household to
stay at home for 14 days if one member
of that household thinks he/she has the
symptoms avoid all unnecessary
gatherings pubs clubs bars restaurants
theaters and so on work from home if you
can wash your hands and we've already
announced in the last few days we will
massively scale up our testing capacity
in the weeks ahead so that we hit 25,000
tests a day huge public information
campaign is being rolled out so people
get all the information they need we
need to protect ourselves and others
were asking retired healthcare
professionals to come back and help us
help the NHS to cope with this
unprecedented challenge and we will
continue as we have from the beginning
to do the right thing at the right time
and to follow the best scientific advice
and we come today to the key issue of
schools where we've been consistently
advised that there is an important
trade-off and so far the judgment of our
advisors has been that closing schools
is actually of limited value in slowing
the spread of the epidemic and that's
partly because counterintuitive these
schools are actually very safe
environments and in this disease in this
epidemic children and young people are
much less vulnerable and hitherto the
advice has been that we should keep
schools open if possible in order to
reduce the pressure on the NHS and on
all other public services but I think
you'll agree that I've always been very
clear this is a balanced judgement and
one that we've kept under
constant review so looking at the curve
of the disease and looking at where we
are now we think now that we must apply
downward pressure further downward
pressure on that upward curve by closing
the school so I can announce today and
Gavin Williamson is making a statement
now in that in the House of Commons that
after schools shut their gates from
Friday afternoon they will remain closed
for most pupils for the vast majority of
pupils until further notice and I'll
come to I'll explain what I mean by the
vast majority of pupils the objective is
to slow the spread of the virus and as I
say we judge that this is the right
moment to do that but of course as I've
always said we also need to keep the NHS
going and to treat the rising number of
cases so we need health workers who are
also parents to continue to go to work
and we need other critical workers with
children to keep doing their jobs - from
police officers who are keeping our safe
to the supermarket delivery drivers
social care workers who look after the
elderly and who are so vital we'll be
setting out more details shortly about
who we mean whom we mean in these groups
so we therefore need schools to make
provision for the children of these key
workers who would otherwise be forced to
stay home and they will also need to
look after the most vulnerable children
this will mean that that would cause be
far fewer children in the schools and
that will help us to slow the spread of
the disease and these measures are
crucial to make sure that the as I say
the critical parts of the economy keep
functioning and public services keep
functioning
so we're simultaneously asking nurseries
and private schools to do the same and
we're providing financial support where
it's needed
we're making provisions to supply meals
and vouchers for children eligible for
free school meals and where some schools
are already doing this I want to make it
clear that we will reimburse the cost
and of course this does mean that exams
will not take place as planned in May
and do though we will make sure that
pupils get the qualifications they need
and deserve for their academic career
now I know that these steps will not be
easy for parents or for teachers and for
many parents this will be frustrating
and it will make it harder for them to
go out to work and of course that's one
of the reasons that we haven't wanted to
go ahead and that's why we're now
working on further measures to ensure
that we support not just businesses but
also individuals and their families to
keep our economy going as Ritchie soon
Act the Chancellor outlined yesterday I
also need to remind parents as we've
already advised that children should not
be left with older grandparents or older
relatives who may be particularly
vulnerable you have fallen into some of
the vulnerable groups and I want to I
know that's going to be difficult too
and I want to thank families for their
sacrifice at this difficult time and I
want to thank the whole country for the
efforts that people are making to comply
with these measures I particularly want
to thank teachers head teachers all the
support staff who keep schools going who
are going to be able to make these
exceptional arrangements work for the
benefit of us all by looking after the
children of key workers they will be a
critical part of our fight back against
coronavirus and as I've said we will
take the right steps at the right time
guided by the science we believe that
the steps we've already taken together
with those I'm announcing today are
already slowing the spread of the
disease but we will not hesitate to go
further
and faster in the days and weeks ahead
and we will do whatever it takes so that
we beat it together and I'm not going
too fast I think to to Patrick to give
an update from sages point of view Thank
You overriding consideration has always
save lives protect the most vulnerable
people from this illness the vast
majority of people have a mild illness
but some get a very severe illness the
measures that were announced a couple of
days ago we already know are taking
effect in terms of behavior so we can
see that already that people have
actually taken that very seriously and
have made a difference and that's really
important to carry on with that but the
thing we must protect in order to
achieve those aims of saving lives and
protecting people is to make sure that
the NHS intensive care capacity and the
ventilator capacity is not breached
that's what we need to keep looking at
making sure we do not get to a position
where that's breached as this moves fast
and I alluded to this on Monday more
measures will be needed to make sure
that happens and right from the
beginning we said schools are one of the
things you can do but they're less
important than some of the others that
have been taken but we now think with a
stage where this extra bit is an
important measure to make sure we stay
under that critical protecting the NHS
ICU and ventilator capacity so that's
the reason for now saying that this
should go ahead at this time it's
important to stress and this is really
critical it's not because schools are
dangerous places for children they're
not children have a very mild or
asymptomatic version of this disease in
many cases so they are are the least at
risk it's also not a dangerous place for
teachers the reason for this is because
of the effect it can have just to knock
down further the transmission the put
some delay into the system put some
breaks into the system of the
transmission of this disease to bring it
down
to protect those people who might get
them much more serious version and end
up in intensive care or on a ventilator
so that's the reason now is important
time to do it it's not instead of and it
can't supplement the other measures the
other measures are crucially important
and we all have our part to play to make
sure that we may make those measures as
effective as possible so try to drive
this right down and make sure we stay
below that critical threshold thank you
thank you so much Patrick oh Jenny from
your point of view so I think nothing
very much further to add to those points
exactly the practices are explained this
is not a change in the scientific
position which we've always taken
forward it is very much a practical
response at a critical time as both
Prime Minister and some Patrick as has
indicated but very happy to answer any
clinical questions that comes okay Axl
well thank you thank you very much